Hi folks. Hi everyone, and I'm happy to see you. My name is Dimitri and
Today when this series of video I will walk you through
decentralized AI
What's even going on right now? Who are miners? Who are validators?
What are you doing? And in the end of these recordings you will understand
what's going on really and it will help you to connect all the dots and
Why you're doing that? So first things first
decentralized AI right the white even matters and
how you can
really
leverage how you can leverage it to use in your life in your career and
etc. So
Recently just a month ago. The big milestone was achieved in decentralized AI world
It was the proof of concept see because the first
Big LLM was trained using only decentralized resources
so without multi-million dollars of investment without huge energy costs and thousands of thousands hours of
Engineers in some big enterprise companies. So everything happened on
decentralized net and
Today I will walk you through
decentralization
Why it even appear in the world, right?
What is bit tensor? What is subnets? Who are miners?
validators then I will speak a little bit about
Bitbridge about our team and what we've accomplished and in the very end
I will show you what you are really working on and how it looks
behind the scenes
So I think you don't you don't really think about AI
just in terms of the open charge if it has the question and get an answer see if so, it's pretty simple and
with all your business school or other schools
with all your education inside Yukon, I think you
utilizes and
Uses AI in general more than just
Ask the question and I get an answer. So if we zoom out from from this vision, it's
Every major technological revolution looked like this a few players build the system and then they control the access
Resources and benefits and everyone else becomes a user. This is what's really different right now with decentralized AI
For the first time in history, you can be actually who build who contribute and have an opportunity to participate
Yeah, just imagine if intelligence in general if and
resources and
computational power worked like
Intelligence like a big net. This is the core idea of decentralized AI
Instead of one company instead of one big enterprise instead of call-up or sorry instead of the
Google instead of the Microsoft or open AI or entropic
There is thousands and thousands of contributors that are produced independent models
computation and
They also produce intelligence in general and they the more important they
Compete against each other. So it's imagine. It's like the
infinite evolution
Infinite evolution flow and they have the one goal to improve to get more rewards
So core is the very simple the strongest contributors get rewarded based on the merit
Nor is a man who experience no connections just whoever
Produced the best performance and best results
And the question is how do you organize?
Such a thing. There are different visions on
decentralized
Detritalization in general, but we will show you how the tensor look on the decentralization and
So imagine the tensor as the big network
It's the large network that are broke down into small parts
That are called subnets as you can see on this picture. So subnets. It's the
Look at this the subnet means the startup startup inside the bigger network. So each startup has the
Different utility different goals and different types of solutions
but
Yeah, and inside into this startup is the full ecosystem. So is the
Smaller ecosystem inside the bigger ecosystem that that potential so huge big big
Sorry, huge ecosystem is the potential and there are a lot of small startups called subnets inside this
ecosystem that are
separate from the
Sorry that are not separate I'm sorry that are
They have their own goals and they achieve it in their own ways
So yeah core idea is that the tensor uses
this subnets
Which are essentially the different visions of the AI
in simple words the
Bit tensor, it's that decentralized AI
platform that are running on a blockchain and
You can think about the blockchain as the public data set that no one person or entity controls and
It's verifiable and where models and contributors compete and calibrate
Speaking about the core mechanism
I will show you on the next slide, but the miners they produce work
validators they evaluate quality of this work and the network in general
It assigned rewards for the best performance
Automatically based on some rules or incentive mechanisms
Okay, I will take a pause here and I will continue with the next next slide with the
more easy explanation